mais comment ils vont la bon désormais
je porte des lunettes mais un maximum de
reflets touch et pas les mêmes alors oui
vu qu'en ce moment je suis en plein
déménagement je tourne cette vidéo
depuis mon bureau à mon bureau c'est
plus une forme d' amis un dressing
garage à vélos débarras parce que vous
voulez en fait plus je fais des vidéos
plus mon décor est pourri alors en ce
moment j'essaye de repasser mon pote
ouais j'ai toujours pas ouais ça fait
dix ans enfin je lui mets gelé périmés
développer ce détail et sur un staff
vous avez été 61 mille huit cents à
vouloir une vidéo sur le code
bon bah voilà c'est parti alors oui il
ya dix ans j'ai déjà essayé de passer
mon code est ce que dans le passé vous
avez déjà été motorisés c'est à dire au
niveau des bras j'aurais de vous dire
évolution de ma vie depuis dix ans
si j'ai quand même un peu évolué jeu
quand même passer du vélo au bel
électrique ça m'angoisse de me dire que
les gens qui ont vu ma vieille vidéo sur
le code en 2011
depuis ils ont tous eu leur permis de
repousser en caisse et vivent leur
meilleur life
moi je tourne la repasser mon code au
bout de dix ans du coup et je me suis
remis
re réviser le code en ligne évidemment
non je dis ça parce que moi qui suis né
à la préhistoire à l'époque le code
n'était pas en ligne c'était pas sur une
appli ou sur un site est allé dans un
seul endroit dans une pièce il y avait
des gens que tu ne connaissais pas il y
avait un mec est en train la pièce dont
le métier était de faire ceci
bonjour au revoir
depuis cette époque le code il a
vachement évolué il ya plein de
nouvelles questions et à plein de
nouvelles réglementations ça fait deux
semaines que je révise et à des mots
vraiment je ne peux plus de mots
chaussée zebra terre plein central
bas-côté marquage au sol signalisation
et carrefour à sens giratoire
ouais enfin tu vas dire un rond-point
qua non surtout pas
alors je découvre ou redécouvre plein de
panneaux rares si tu les as pas a pris
un jour tu peux pas les deviner zone de
passage à la vitesse de la lumière
échange de porte-clés en forme de
voiture puis de sacs quadrillé waouh
route étonnante justement à fond dans
mes révision du code en ce moment que
quand je joue à forte night des fois je
suis là genre à temps mais c'est qu'il
panos a déjà liesse haye
merci de faire irruption dans la vidéo à
komotini au monde et core i need you
[ __ ] j'ai mis dix jours elle préparait
ce décor dans le code
je trouve que les questions elles sont
bien mais le niveau n'est pas toujours
équilibré franchement soissons trop
facile soit sont trop durs frères défaut
les questions ces genres la ceinture est
correctement installé mais franchement
mais dans ces pays s'ils répondent au
genre il fait chaud je peux circuler le
capot ouvert
est ce que mon véhicule et bien garé je
suis apte à prendre la route
oui à condition d'utiliser un outil
grattoir l'usagé adoptent une conduite
correcte
je lui propose un test pcr ça n'a aucun
rapport
mon tableau de bord va m'indiquer le
tableau de bord a fondu dans cette
situation j'accélère et j'insulte
nerveusement je m'arrête
alors que choisir sachant que la réponse
n'est pas à
et en plus la réponse et b allez-y
furent maintenant bbbb je cède le
passage j'ai le droit de conduire ce
véhicule
mon animal de compagnie est correctement
installé
donc tu dis c'est easy je vais gérer le
code en trois jours et il arrive de
nouvelles questions péter haas et 1,6 mm
la dizaine de la vitesse
non mais le vélo c'est bien aussi vous
des foyers des questions ambiguës sait
très bien que dans la situation du gérer
mais la question telle qu'elle est
formulée s'est tordu sais pas quoi
répondre
dans cette situation quelle est la zone
de danger principal j'ai pas vu quand tu
conduis tu tchèque tout s'est tu te fais
pas un top 10 dans l'ordre des dangers
possibles
les gens qui font le code là pourquoi
vous mettez des pièges jacques le code
c'est pas évident pourquoi vous mettez
des pièges on dirait vous kiffez nous
faire échouer
ok les gars je vous rappelle comment
créer une question du code de la route
question piège dépression je veux que le
candidat soit égoutter pense avant la
bonne réponse et piège
pour ce faire trois fautes et dac 14 il
rentre chez lui
crises d angoisse divorce légaux saada
ce jeu vous ruiner sa lite
non après dans le quota de tout un tas
des questions genre administrative avec
un permis probatoire le capital initial
est de 6 points 9 points récupérable en
un an 6 mois à temps mais moi je veux
conduire je peux pas travailler à la
préfecture et puis il ya des questions
chelou dans cet embouteillage mon
passager peut rester installé de cette
façon j'ai passé quitté potes nous en
passager il fait ça je laisse sur
l'autoroute
narry voilà après faut réviser un ya pas
de secret mais c'est bizarre on dirait
que plus je m'entraîne plus je fais des
fautes c'est incompréhensible
regardez ma courbe de progression le mec
régresse quand tu révises le code des
fois tu commences à série est au bout de
cinq questions tu as déjà cinq fautes et
là tu connais la petite technique
non mais je recommençais j'étais pas
dedans après des questions franchement
je n'ai plus de place dans le coffre
le mieux est de placer mes bagages dans
un coffre de toit ok c'est mieux ils ont
raison c'est sûr mais excuse moi ce qui
respecte vraiment tout à la lettre tu
diras carrément au look et les voilà
tous entre quoi ça ça va dans le coffre
de toit pape a continué [ __ ] j'ai pas
du concorde en tout cas voilà j'avais
visé le code pendant plusieurs semaines
franchement sérieusement donc j'espère
que je vais la voir j'ai mon examen dans
quelques jours donc on va voir ça a
donné un le jour j y croise ailleurs le
grand jour est arrivé
franchement j'ai réalisé que raouf en
deux semaines non-stop tous les jours
donc ça devrait le faire à moi qui met
des questions tordues la sq il
soufflerait mais bon est par exemple
plus facile à l'examen que les questions
importune révise donc je croise les
doigts
c'est le lieu est accueillant j'ai envie
j'ai besoin je pense qu'on drevet là
[Musique]
ouais
ok je pense j'ai fait 3 4 points 4
fautes
première question je plat sur vos
réponses dans une demi heure hier
merci la poste pose bon à la base je
voulais me filmer en train de découvrir
mes résultats mais en fait on m'a
totalement cinglé mais résultats hors
caméra j'ai donc le regret de vous
annoncer que j'ai eu
bon bah je suis trop content d'avoir une
- quote ça faisait dix ans que
j'attendais ça j'ai fait quatre fautes 1
pour ceux que ça intéresse aussi le
monde s'en fout voilà j'ai un peu galéré
l'avoir parce que je suis un nul et un
flemmard
et franchement les codes de la route
sont vraiment trop bien fait donc je
vous recommande de bien réviser au
maximum c'est hyper important pour votre
sécurité et celle des autres vraiment
sapho faut vraiment garder ça en tête
ceux qui passent le code en ce moment je
donne un maximum de force je vous
encourage à bien réviser à la voir moi
je les passais sur ornicar alors c'est
pas une bulle du tout mais juste voilà
je les trouvais super bien foutu et
naples 1 qui sont coulés aussi en
voiture simone
auto école pour annoter tout faire
franchement vous trouverez facilement
votre bonheur et même si vous avez le
code et les permis et où faut garder en
tête que la voiture c'est pas toujours
indispensable surtout pour les trajets
courts abonnez-vous la chaîne de nono
comme ça et gagnera un max de thune
donnez nous une nouvelle corde à se
morfondre
oh
juste
un à l'école